I never pictured
a world where marijuana
would be anywhere close
to legal.
And it's mind blowing to me
that mushrooms are being
decriminalized everywhere.
Comedian Shane Mauss tours the
country discussing his psychedelic
experiences.
But I know that I'm hallucinating.
I don't think that it's real.
I'm not like, "Oh my God.
The walls are bleeding."
It's more like, "Oh my God, the
walls are bleeding."
Reason caught up with him at the
Psychedelics Science 2023
Conference held in Denver this June,
where he participated in a roast
of the psychedelic scene.
DMT is always "Ah man
if I would have just would have
pulled the thing out
that it was telling me if I just
would have remembered the thing.
Oh, could have saved the planet.
Better smoke it again I got a planet
to save.
The conference was sponsored by the
Multidisciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies or MAPS,
and a reported 13,000
people gathered in the Mile High
City to discuss every
aspect of drug policy, research
and culture.
Mauss, who also hosts a science
podcast called "Here We Are" shared
his thoughts about the mainstreaming
of psychedelic drugs, the surprising
pace of legalization efforts,
and the role that Joe Rogan and
other public figures play
in normalizing psychedelics.
We're in a psychedelic renaissance,
a lot of people call it, and it's
certainly a psychedelic moment.
Like what? What does the psychedelic
Renaissance mean to you?
I don't know what the psychedelic
Renaissance means to me.
I can tell you that as
someone who was born
in 1980 and
experienced much of the
Reagan era, Just Say
No to drugs and early
nineties PSAs and
the frying egg and
"this is your brain on drugs" type
stuff, I never pictured
a world where marijuana
would be anywhere
close to legal,
and it's mind blowing to me
that mushrooms are being
decriminalized everywhere.
I started a science podcast "Here We
Are" eight years ago, and at that
time the number
of organizations even attempting
to jump through all of the
regulatory hoops to
just test psychedelics in any
way at all was there was just
MAPS, which was much smaller even
just eight years ago doing it and
a couple other small organizations.
And and now it's
there's all sorts of Johns Hopkins
and and Stanford and
a zillion universities
are getting involved.
What do you think changed?
Like why? Why, why now?
Why are psychedelics suddenly
everywhere?
Yeah, that is a very good question.
I.
I think.
Hmm.
Why now?
I have no idea.
I don't know. I don't know what
changed. I don't know
if this is just
what progress looks like.
And it's inevitable.
I, I, I don't know that
that's the case. I have.
I have no idea.
I didn't see this coming.
I think that maybe just
the war on drugs was such
horrible policy
in the first place that it was never
going to last.
So it's kind of like communism,
right?
Eventually it runs out of something.
Yeah, perhaps.
I don't know.
I. I don't know.
I don't know enough about public
policy to speculate
on.
One of the things. I mean, you
you know, you're kind of a
psychedelic comedian, right?
Yeah.
I mean, you talk a lot about that.
You have a show which is
built around your psychedelic
experiences.
What do you like about psychedelics?
Psychedelics just changed my life.
I did them just as kind of a goof
when I was a teenager, just to be a
rebel or whatever.
And I had smoked weed
and laughed a bunch and
thought it was great.
But psychedelics were something more
meaningful for me.
I always had pretty serious
depression issues from the age of
ten years old, I would say,
and they were something that really
helped with that.
When we say "they" what?
What kinds of psychedelics are you
talking about?
Mushrooms were my all time favorite,
my go to for a very, very long time.
And then
I think if it weren't for DMT,
I probably wouldn't have a science
podcast. I was always
interested in how the mind worked.
And then when I first
smoked DMT, I became absolutely
obsessed with trying to figure out
what the heck was that.
What was the can you describe the
experience that you had that you're
like, "I got to figure out what's
going on here.